やばい遅刻するお腹痛いよキータ急げやす
僕のことは置いて先に行ってくれでもいい
から行くん
だお前の分まで背負って走る
[音楽]
ぞ1秒遅刻よ廊下に刺さってろ
なんでお母さんがここにあれは昨日の夕方
相変わらず助は問題地で校舎を破壊したり
いたずらしたりめちゃくちゃですよ親の顔
が見てみたいよオタクの教育はどうなっ
てるんですかオタクの教育こそどうなっ
てるんですかはああんたの先生としての
能力が低いからそうなってるんじゃない
そんなこと言うなお前が先生をやってみた
いいわよ
え今日から私がこの学校
の先生になる
わバンカ
ラジオ今日からこのクラスの担任になった
プリティティーチャーきこ
ですお母さん頭悪いのに先生なんてできる
のお母さんじゃなくて先生って呼びなさい
せ先生
語の授業です漢字は体で感じるのが漢字な
の
よ
[音楽]
例えばそれ
じゃあウンウンこの感じを覚えてもらい
ます
ウ何するつもりだ
[音楽]
はいこれがマジ見えなきゃ意味ない
だろ
はい
はいそれじゃあ今日覚えたことをテストし
ます始め
それじゃあ点数を発表するわやす100点
こじり60点う50点歌と0点みんなが
100点取れるまでテストは受けなしえお
仕置きよ100点取れないとだめだめだめ
だめ
[拍手]
それじゃあ始めなんとか先生にバレない
ようにみんなに答えを教え
なきゃ教科書映せば100点なん
よあんた何してん
のな何って教科書映してるだけなんよ
カンニングしたらだめだめだめだめわ
今回のテストはカンニングがないように
厳しくするわここはこちピアス2だ
お母さんの監視能力が強化された
始めわからない
よ先生熱いので暖房切ってもらってもいい
ですかこのダミの手に注目しているうちに
後ろで問題の答えを任がさせるん
だどうやらばれてないみたい
だ感じがわからない
よ虫メガネを使って太陽光を反射させる
お母さんの資格に答えを書き出すん
だ2問目も溶けたみたい
だ残りは1
問分からないよそうなったら消しゴムに
変えた答え
を上履きと共に
[音楽]
運ぶ
うんやばいどうやらバレたみたいだ
[音楽]
助かっ
た終了
ですそれじゃあ点数を発表するわ100点
100点ト100点勝っ
たすカンニングさせるのに夢中で書くの
忘れてた
それじゃ仕置きと行こう
かしら3+3
はじゃこの問題分かる人6ぶ正解は
ショッピーが3人とリチが3人合わせて超
かっこいいでし
たあれ
なかったかしらそれじゃあ1話の2
は0.5ぷぷー正解はあ俺のスイッチ
分かりやすく説明するために家から持って
きまし
たはい1つのスイッチが2つになったので
2個でした何してんだめちゃ分かりやすい
よそれじゃあ先生この問題は三角形ABC
の変BC上Pが自由に動きます三角形AB
の面積とACPの面積が等しくなるのは
どの位置にテPを置いた時でしょうか任せ
なさい先生が体で教えてあげるわなんか嫌
な予感が
するまずはABCPに分かれて三角形を
作りなさいよくやるんよ俺はA私はB僕は
Cこれで決まりね変BCの上をPが動くの
よしっかり体で覚え
[音楽]
なさいそれじゃあ変BCの上自由に動き
なさい自由に動くテピが目障りなので動き
を止め
ますやねちゃん三角形の面積の求め方って
何だっけ底辺かける高さある2だけどそし
たらあんたは底辺になり
なさいああ
次は高さを求める
わ
ら底辺と高さは分かったからあと
は悪によ
あ絶対に復讐して
やる今日はショピ算をやっていくわよ
ショッピーが先生この問題が分からないの
で実演してもらってもいいですかうん
さっきの三角形が地球太陽火星になっ
たってことねそれじゃあやって
[音楽]
みよう行っ
てらっしゃいやっと邪魔者が消えた
1+1の答えはきこが2人になるから
めちゃくちゃうい
[拍手]
ですそれじゃあみんな前回の問題の復習で
もしましょうかしらあちちのテがみんなの
ことを売れたらどうなるでしょうれ
の時間ですようやく給食だいただき
ますそんな小さな声じゃ食材にも失え
でしょもっと腹のぜいただきますもっと
いただきますほらもっと式呼吸を意識して
じ
わよし食べていい
わほらあなたごめんなさい給食費払えなく
て僕の分の給食ないん
よそうなの
[音楽]
ああんたその箸の持ち方は何なの僕の家お
金持ちでフレンジしか食べないから箸は
使わないんだこの水を全部箸で映し終える
まで給食は食べちゃためよ
ごちそうさでした巻き込まれる前に早く
帰ろ給食は全部食べるまでが給食よは俺の
目はもう食べただろあんたの給食費を払っ
てるのは私よどうせ食べるならたくさん
食べた方がお得でしょくそこんなに
いっぱい食えるわけないだろそれにこいつ
らも頼りになら
ないゆう
とそっかユトに給食を食べさせればいいの
かお腹が空いたんよ先生さすがにゆとにも
給食を食べさせてください給食費払って
ないからだめよ教育基本法第4条全ての
国民は等しくその能力に応じた教育を
受ける機会を与えなければならない給食も
学校教育の一部なので経済状況で差を
つつけるのはアウトですよねぐねねねは
ちょっと待ってなさい
[音楽]
[拍手]
よおいしくなれおいしくなれ
[音楽]
ややったった
よいしょごそ様なんよありがとうゆうと
できた
お全部食べてえらいわねはいこれきこ特性
栄養満点黒炎
鍋ほら
あー言と我慢
[音楽]
だ
わお前らナイスてだ
[音楽]
みんな明日はグミ工場を見学しますグミ
ステップグミステップグミグミグ中合時間
には遅れないように来るのよ
はいグミグミ
ググ工場って本当にここであってんのかな
ほらこんなところに何のようだ場見学でき
たんよここはヤザの事務所黒だぞ組違い
じゃねえ
[音楽]
かてかあの子た遅いわ
ね君は何をしてるんだ大変なことになっ
てるぞははにゃこれを見なさいきこにつる
今すぐ全てのあり金持ってここに来
もちろん1人
だ寒い
と可愛い可い子供たちの命は保証されない
ぞ校長先生給料の前借りはできるかしら
できるがこれは君の初任だぞもちろんお金
は払わないけどねねえ
[拍手]
よく来たな生徒たちを返しなさいこいつら
にはたっぷりと裏社会の授業をしてあげた
ぜで約束の金はこれ
[音楽]
よめてんのか
よくもやりやがったなおりゃ
あおりゃおりゃおりゃ
おりゃ
ああおいこれ以上バカな真似はよせ
どこだどこだ
[拍手]
あみな怖い思いさせてごめんね
先生はい取ってあげるらはい早いどうぞほ
[音楽]
お母さんお母さん
おさん作戦成功です
ね組違いじゃねえかお前らただじゃ返さ
ねえぞ僕たちを弟子にして
ください親のについて一に先生をやっつけ
たいんですお前親に何言ってんお
嫌いじゃねえぞ学校で教えてくれねえこと
をお前に教えてやるよこれぞまさにちぎり
ちぎりちぎりちぎりちろちろこうして俺
たちはヤザとちぎりをかわし嘘の犯罪予告
を行っ
た皆さんいい元でしたごめんねみな大丈夫
これが真実
だ正義は
くらね完璧なしぎでしたよ
[拍手]
やぶ
ポンあんたたちよくも私を騙した
[音楽]
ねわあ
きこ先生校長先生がお呼びです
よ生徒を危険にさすなんて教師失格浜井
先生もクズだけどお母さんよりマだ
な何がプリティティーチャーきこだはい君
は今日から
お前ら寂しい思いさせてっ
た薬座組織を壊滅させたことが校長先生
から表彰されました
えそして今日からプリティ校長きこになり
まし
たこ君は首
だ今日は数のジグです今日のテピは誰かな
逃げろなさ